Jake, you believe that Jesus is gonna
come back, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Uh what's he going to do? Give us
a couple descriptions if you can.
>> Uh there are numerous hadith about it. I
don't know what have you have in mind
specifically but he's going to come and
the different hadiths speak about him
breaking the cross killing the pigs
which is symbolic of actually uh the
fact that Jews and Christians um sorry
Christians are actually not properly
following the correct law and they're
eating pig and they're essentially
worshiping the cross but that's one
aspect and he's going to come under the
sharia under the laws of the prophet
Muhammad and call people to guidance.
>> Also, um, you missed one. Um, what's he
gonna do about [clears throat] the
Jizia?
>> Sorry.
>> What's he going to do about the Jizia?
>> The Jiza at that time will no longer be
valid because of the fact,
>> let me let me finish. The Jizia the Jiza
at that particular moment in time will
no longer be valid because of the fact
that the it's too late and the people
either accept Islam or they don't. Those
are the only two options at that point.
So you agree that Jesus is going to be
the one that abolishes the law of Jizia?
>> No.
>> No. Jesus Jesus is going to come and at
the time when he comes because it's the
end times, the Jiza is no longer
applicable. That doesn't help with your
Islamic dilemma. You got to try harder.
>> I'm going to ask you one last time. I'm
going to give you a chance before I
bring this up. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Is Jes according to the hadith, does
Jesus abolish the Jiza? Yes.
>> No. It's Allah who abolishes the Jiza.
It's Allah who abolishes the Jiza and
Jesus is sent as a prophet. We don't
believe that the prophet Jesus is making
his own laws independent of Allah. Thank
you.
>> Okay, I got you. So, we're going to go
to the hadith really quick and I want to
just bring this up for you because you
said according to the Hadith, Jesus is
not the one who is abolishing the Jiza.
So
>> I said that prophets I said that
prophets when they bring laws they are
receiving revelation from God and based
upon that that's the laws that they're
bringing.
>> I got you. So I'm going to ask it again.
Does
>> it does Jesus abolish the Jizia? Yes or
no?
>> I already answered that. I said that the
prophet Jesus and all prophets receive
revelation and based upon that they
bring laws. But even if even if you
wanted to say that Jesus came and
independently
abolished Ajizia, that would not help
you at all whatsoever in the Islamic
dilemma.
>> Okay, here's Sah Bkari 2476. This is one
of many, ladies and gentlemen. It says,
and I'm going to ask this in the
question narrated Abu Herrera. Allah's
apostle said, "The hour will not be
established until the son of Mary
descends amongst you as a just ruler. He
will break the cross, kill the pigs, and
abolish the jizzy attacks.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So, does the law that Jesus when Jesus
is coming, is he, according to what I
just read, going to abolish the jizzy
attacks?
>> As I said, he is doing it based upon
revelation. So, he is doing it.
>> He's doing it based upon revelation. And
that doesn't change anything. You have
to establish.
>> I bet it doesn't. We're just getting
started, man.
point. You have to explain how it
changes anything related to the Islamic
dilemma.
>> We're going to but this is you haven't
shown anything.
>> The point is your your argument does not
touch the Islamic dilemma, but I'm
obliging. Okay, we're going to see.
Okay, we're going to see. So, okay,
we're going to get busted up.
>> Okay. Okay, cool. So, according to you,
this is a slow this is a slow
>> slow simmer. Exactly. It's simmering too
slow. We don't even notice.
>> So, according to you, according to you,
you just contradicted yourself. No, I
didn't. You contradicted yourself. I
know you're slow, but it's Hold on. Hold
on. Let me
>> ask A QUESTION, BRO. YOU'RE JUST
TALKING. YOU HAVE TO ASK.
>> All right, guys. Guys, guys, guys, guys.
All right,
>> ask a question.
>> Come on now. Get the question out,
Avery. Let's go.
>> All right. So, according to what you
just said, you contradicted yourself and
said that Jesus does pay the uh does
abolish the Jizia tax through revelation
that God gives him. Okay.
>> I said that from the beginning. Where's
the contradiction? So, here's my
question. Here's my we'll remind the
tape.
>> Exactly. I said it from the beginning.
>> Here's my question. Okay. So when Jesus
comes and abolishes the JY attacks, does
that mean that his revelation is an
authority over the Quran?
>> NO.
>> OH. SO, SO uh uh by bringing a new law
or abregating a law in the previous
revelation does not mean that this new
revelation is now an authority over the
previous.
>> No, because this was foretold since the
beginning. The hadith that's mentioned
over the hadith that's mentioned. Yeah.
It's over for you cuz you don't you
still don't understand your own
argument. It's so pathetic. It's so
pathetic.
>> Jesus, let me get the book out for you.
>> Jesus Yeah. Jesus is receiving
revelation. Jesus is receiving
revelation. And at that time, the Jiza
is no longer prescribed. It's no longer
an option for humanity to actually take.
That's the point.
>> Got it. So, just to make sure I got it
all down, what's the
>> Yeah, get it all down. Go ahead.
>> All right. So, we got that. Uh,
>> can we get a question here? Are we going
to get a question?
>> Let's let's get a question, David. Let's
get a question.
>> All right. Thank you. All right. So, it
looks like we got rid of the the whole
authority type of thing and Jizia uh
dilemma.
>> No, we have.
>> So, my my my question is this now. Um,
according to chapter 3:81, you agree
that Allah made a covenant with the
prophets, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And the covenant was that he has given
them a book and has given them wisdom.
And um on Allah's end of the bargain,
he's going to send a messenger that
confirms what they have. Correct.
>> Uh I don't have it up before me. Uh I'm
just pulling it up now.
>> You don't memorize it? You don't
memorize?
>> No, I don't have the entire Quran
memorized. Do you?
>> Oh, another one that doesn't memorize.
>> Do you?
>> I don't think so.
>> Uh yeah. It says, "And recall of the
prophets when Allah took the covenant of
the prophets, saying, "Whatever I give
you of the scripture and wisdom, and
then there comes to a messenger
confirming what is with you, you must
believe in him and support him." Allah
said, "Have you acknowledged and taken
upon my co commitment?" They said, "We
have acknowledged it." He said, "Then
bear witness and I am with you among the
witnesses."
>> So the Allah's end of the bargain is to
send a messenger that confirms what they
have. Correct?
>> Right. And you must including you, the
people of the book, must believe in him
and support him.
>> Very good. How do they recognize this
messenger? in their scriptures and based
upon one way is based upon their
scriptures and there's also independent
evidence in terms of miracles,
prophecies and other things
>> in accordance of the covenant. How do
they recognize it? Please, it's right in
there in the verse. You just read it.
>> Yeah, it says whatever I give you of the
scripture and wisdom and then there
comes to a messenger confirming what is
with you, you must believe in him and
support him. Show me in the verse where
it actually says that's the reason why.
>> That's not supposed to be your
>> exactly you. It's not there.
>> Hold on a second. So according to the to
the verse, the messenger is going to
come confirming what they have. Correct.
>> Exactly. Confirming what is with you.
>> I got you. So now and as a result,
they're supposed to believe in him and
support him. Correct.
>> That's part of it. Yep.
>> Okay. So if a messenger comes and
contradicts what they have, will they
have grounds to judge that messenger as
a false messenger?
>> Uh the people of the book.
>> Yes. Yes, the people the people
>> the people the people of the book if
they have genuine scripture that
disagrees with what what a uh prophet
after them comes with then yes
>> according to the to 381 do they have the
genuine scripture
>> no they do not
>> so they're they do not so I got you so
according to the scripture [laughter]
according to chapter
>> I know you got to laugh you don't have
question so according to chapter 3 verse
81 Allah is sending a messenger to
confirm corrupted books
>> no he's confirm he's coming to actually
as the bring the foran which
distinguishes what is in them.
>> What does it say bring the furan? What
>> where does it say bring the furan there?
>> It's mentioned all throughout the Quran.
>> Okay. Well, it says the conscious. Who
cares? I'm talking about this verse
right here, Jake. According to the
verse, he's supposed to means it means
that it is something which distinguishes
between truth and falsehood, which the
Quran says the Torah is. That's what the
Quran is actually doing. Okay, it's
distinguishing between truth and
falsehood over the previous scriptures.
>> That's not my question though because
no, the Quran doesn't say that. It says
the Torah is the criteria in the foran
as well that also decides what's true
and what's false, what's right and
what's wrong as well. That's chapter
21:48. My question about this verse is
according to this verse, it says that
the messenger is going to come
confirming what they have. Does that
mean that what they have is true
scripture?
>> Not all of it. No.
>> So then he's going to be confirming
corrupted books. No, he's going to be
confirming he's going to be confirming
what is correct and he's going to be
disagreeing with what what is incorrect
as he explicitly does all throughout the
Quran.
>> I got you. Okay. So, in chapter 3 81
when it says that there that they're
going to he's going to come and he's
going to confirm what's with them.
You're saying that what's with them is
partially true and partially uh
corrupted. Is that right? Just as Quran
350 says that Isaam or Jesus is going to
come and confirm the Torah while at the
same time he actually abregates laws
from it. So it's not a total
confirmation in the way that you
imagine.
>> I got you. So when the Quran you you
agree that the Quran abrogates itself
correct?
>> Uh yeah in certain circumstances.
>> Okay. And so in circumstances when the
Quran abrogates that guys abrogation
means when the Quran is bringing a a new
law or something else to substitute
another verse. So when the Quran comes
and abregates its own verses, is the
Quran saying that the Quran is partially
true and partially false?
>> No, it's saying that it's saying that
it's partially authoritative. It's not
fully authority.
>> I got you. So there's some verses. Track
the argument, buddy. You're not
tracking. You're not tracking the
argument.
>> So So according So according to even
abrogation, it's still affirming that
the entire thing is true. Correct.
>> It could be true, but laws from it can
be abregated, which you haven't dealt
with at all.
>> Oh, yeah. I got you. So things can be
true the even though certain laws are
not binding anymore. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> So just because abrogation comes doesn't
mean that what what is being abregated
is false or corrupted. Correct.
>> And I never said that that meant THAT
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU ARGUE. NEVER SAID THAT.
I KNOW YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT SLOW, BRO,
but you're going to catch us by the end
of it. Allah give me
I know
>> you can't catch on. When did I ever say
that abrogation equal corruption? never
said that.
>> I got you. So, so
>> I know you're slow, but David and
Shimoon are too. They can't catch up.
>> You going to have to watch your clip
back after.
>> Yeah, you're going to have to watch it
when I never said that abrogation meant
corruption. Never said that. In fact, I
explicitly denied it. Try to keep up,
bro. You can't keep up with the
argument.
>> I got you. So, according to the verses
that you've been bringing up in your
authority argument, 9:29,
you would agree [clears throat] does not
prove corruption of the previous
scripture. Correct?
>> I never said that it does. It proves
that your scripture is not legally
authoritative over us. Number one, and
number two, that our scripture is
legally authoritative over the Jews and
Christians and your previous scriptures.
Can you actually deal with the argument?
>> Well, the actual argument today, Jake,
is the Islamic dilemma. And telling me
that the Bible is not fully legally
binding on the Muslims or the Musl the
Quran is legally binding on the on the
Christians is not the ISLAMIC DILEMMA.
SO MY QUESTION So my question is in
regards to the Islamic dilemma. Do you
actually have AN ARGUMENT THAT ADDRESSES
THE ISLAMIC DILEMMA?
>> YEAH. I'm going to again have to teach
you your own argument when you spoke to
Danny Boy and you said that the Muslims
actually have to check with the Jews and
scriptures uh Jews and Christians and
their previous scriptures to see whether
or not alcohol is prohibited. And based
upon that, we have to accept whatever it
says. So you're caught. You've had to
change your own argument because you
can't deal with my argument.
>> No, I what I have to do is correct you
on a misrepresentation. Like the verse
says, it's ask those if you are in
doubt. If they're in doubt about what
the Quran says, does it only partially?
>> It says what the Quran what has been
revealed to them.
>> Is it only partially what's been
revealed?
>> Is it partially or fully?
>> What's been revealed?
>> That's not your question. What's been
revealed?
>> What's been revealed to the Jews and
Christians?
>> No, no, no. when it says, "If you are in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you." Thank you. So, okay. So,
according to the Quran, if they're in
doubt about what the Quran says, what
are they supposed to do?
>> Exactly. So, now you're going back and
you're restating you're restating.
You're restating your own argument,
which is that according to you, those
previous scriptures are legally
authoritative for Muslims over the
Quran. Correct. If they do not So you're
asking me a question. You can ask me
that on your time. Let me just
>> because you're not dealing with the
argument.
>> We'll see. So according to 1094, right?
According to the 1094, can you tell what
what does doubt mean? What does it mean
to doubt?
>> To not know something to be true.
>> Correct. Okay, that's awesome. And so if
Muhammad did not know something to be
true in the Quran, what does Allah tell
him to do to get certainty of the truth
about what the Quran is saying? It's not
only speaking to the prophet Muhammad,
it's speaking more generally to Muslims
to go to go to the people of the book
who were reading the scriptures. And if
you look at, let me finish. If you look
at the tapsiers, if you look at our
classical authorities who actually have
an authority, unlike you, we don't care
about your taps. Sorry to tell you. It
says it's to go to the people who
actually understood the truth of Islam
from their scriptures who actually
became Muslims. That's the position.
>> I got you. And what were those people
reading?
>> Those people were reading the previous
scriptures.
>> Thank you. So all that all that flub
didn't matter. So they did. So when it
comes to Here's my question. Now watch
this. So according to the the verse for
Muhammad to get certainty of the truth,
he has to go ask those people who
converted to Islam who are reading the
previous scripture. So if he goes to
these people and he sees that what he's
receiving in the Quran lines up with
what they have, then he'll be certain of
the truth of what he was doubting in the
Quran. Correct. The Quran in that
context. Let me finish. In that context,
if you read the prior verses, it's
talking about the stories of the
prophets and the hardships that they
went through. No worries. And let me
finish. And the prophet peace be upon
him was to go to recognize that the same
thing was taking place for previous
prophets. It's not all encompassing.
>> Okay, no worries. So, let's claim
>> No worries. For the sake of argument,
let me go with you that it's not
all-encompassing. For those PARTICULAR
THINGS, FOR THE sake of the argument
right here, you got to let me get it
out. You're wasting my time. You only
have to follow part of the wast. Ask a
question.
>> Okay. So, stop interrupting. Relax.
>> You keep you keep commenting.
>> I LIKE WHEN MY FOOD TALKS back to me,
but this is tough.
>> All right. Go ahead. Go ahead. Ask a
question.
>> All right. Thank you. So then, so you
said yes that if Muhammad goes and
checks with these people and he sees
that what he's receiving in the Quran
lines up with what they've been reading
in their in their books, then he'll know
that what the Quran is saying is true.
So this means that the opposite is true
as well, right? That if he goes to them
and he sees that what he what he uh what
he's doubting is not in line with what
they have, then he'll know that what he
is receiving is not the truth. Correct.
>> Give me the inference rule for that.
>> So I can you answer the question?
>> No, not necessarily. It doesn't follow
logically.
>> I got you. So
>> it doesn't I know you got to learn cuz
you don't know you don't know what
actually follows and what doesn't.
>> So So you're saying that it it works one
way but it doesn't work the other way.
>> It doesn't necessarily work the other
way. You have to show and give an
argument for that which you haven't
provided.
>> So when I when I
>> You're the one talking over me, right?
Every time I answer the question.
>> No, you're I'm in the middle of asking
the question.
>> No, I was answering and you keep
interrupting.
>> All right. So you done with your answer?
>> Yeah. Now I'm done.
>> Okay. All right. [laughter]
So just like you said it's you said yes
if he goes to them and sees that what he
has lines up with what they what they
have then he'll know that he has the
truth. That means that the inverse is
true that if he goes to them and sees
that it doesn't line up with what they
have then he'll know that it is false.
Correct.
>> Wrong. What is the inference rule for
that? Can you provide it?
>> It's okay if
>> you hell you can. I know. It's okay.
Yeah. It's not your It's not your cross.
It's not your cross. It's it's all being
exposed. It's all good. Yeah, it is.
>> So, so then earlier you said that if the
messenger came and disagreed with what
they had, didn't confirm what they had,
then they will be a they will rightfully
be able to judge him as a false prophet.
Correct. You said that earlier, right?
>> Ask it again. Sorry.
>> You said say it again.
>> Yeah, I didn't hear the question.
>> Okay. You said earlier that you answered
yes. If according to 381, if they uh a
messenger comes and contradicts what
they have, then they then they will have
the right to judge him as a false
messenger. Correct?
>> No. What I said was what I said I know
you want to take your Lord you want to
take your Lord's name in vain in the
church. I understand he's Lord. I know.
Let me finish. I said if according to
what is genuine revelation which they
know to be genuine revelation that if
someone else comes and contradicts it
doesn't matter who or what they're
bringing then yes they would be deemed
false.
>> How do they know if it's genuine
revelation?
>> How do they know what?
>> If it's genuine revelation.
>> They know if it's genuine revelation
based upon what they received and based
upon what THE PROPHET WHAT
>> GUYS BASED upon what the prophet is
coming with. He's able to tell them if
you believe if you believe that he is a
genuine messenger of God which you
quoted earlier that the Jews and
Christians must believe in the Quran
well then they have to also see what the
Quran says and matching with their
supposed scriptures.
>> I got you. Thank you. All right. In
chapter 21 29 verse uh 46 it says to not
dispute with the people of the book
except in fairness um and to say to them
that we believe in what was revealed to
us and what was revealed to you. So my
question is um according to that verse
do they have to believe in part of what
they have?
>> Uh it says do not argue with the people
of the book except in the best way. What
does it have to do with anything? Can
you go to the part where it says say we
believe in what was revealed to us and
what is revealed to you?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, according to the verse, do
they have to are they uh are they able
to believe in part of what they have?
>> They're referring to the genuine
revelation that the people of the book
had.
>> So, is that a yes?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that so it uses it in the same
context as the Quran. Believe in what
what was revealed to us, which is the
Quran. Correct.
>> Uh part of it. Yeah.
>> Oh, so you could believe in part of the
Quran. No, you're you're missing the
point. What is revealed? What is
revealed to you? The prophet peace be
upon him received the Quran and other
revelation besides that. So Quran is
only part of the re
>> when he when it says when you're
disputing with the people of the book
say we believe in what was revealed to
us. Is that the Quran?
>> We believe in that which has been
revealed to us and revealed to you. It's
talking about it's talking about the
previous scriptures or revelation that
the people of the book received and what
the prophet received is the Quran and
the Sunnah.
>> All right. So, stop wasting my time with
that thing.
>> I already
got you. So, according to the verse, are
you able to believe according to the
verse, are you able to believe in part
of the Quran?
>> No.
>> So, then according to the verse, you're
not able to believe in part of what was
revealed to them, right?
>> Exactly.
>> Oh, it's over. Hey, man. Hey, thanks for
coming, man.
>> I never said that.
>> Thanks for coming.
>> Yeah, thanks for coming.
>> It's over. Hey, I I I relax my time and
you can give him the rest. It's over.
>> It's over.
>> It's over for you. It's over.
>> It's a done deal.
>> Yep, it is.
>> All right, guys. Uh let's let's settle
down. Hold your applause. And uh so
we're going to um So you're you're going
you're you're relinquishing the rest of
your time. A you good?
>> Yeah. It's over, bro.